see I'm not a monster  I'm just ahead of the curve Heath Ledger  who oh my God you know what a  performance what a pleasure to have  gotten to work with them and just to see  him you know and how much he put himself  into the Joker and I would and I was  watching it going yeah this is  absolutely fantastic are we in trouble  here of when Chris and I first sat down  we said you're not the problem what  Batman is is that the villains are  always more interesting right and so  Batman actually he's very close to being  a villain himself so let's never let him  become dull by comparison and  unfortunately I was sitting there going  I'm feeling a little bit dull by  comparison because Heath is just like  killing this and uh but I'm so proud of  that film I love it that the Dark Knight  is absolutely extraordinary you know and  it was such a pleasure to have gone away  with these I don't want to kill you what  would I do without you